[Music]
so
oh well i guess i'll be the guy right
wow it's so weird you guys watch this
why is your name sunny choppers because
it's
that's uh alias subscribe my favorite
rapper
who's your favorite rapper um
oh i gotta change my dude i already got
to change my i don't like when i
how do i don't you feel weird here
wait hold on i gotta change it
so they see all this yeah nice i gotta
do the invert
up and down that's that right
yes hell yeah dude i don't play
i go where down is up and up is down
yeah that's right see we're figuring out
it's what life's all about
oh it's like that okay i get it
oh dude this game's cool wow what a turn
it got cool
it wasn't cool for a second yeah because
you were doing that i don't like this is
why i don't like games where you have to
like learn
how to do it i want to know it
immediately
yeah it's a voiceover i don't like the
sound of that
john wayne so these things move or what
oh i bet you gotta jump oh by the way
where are you
i'm not hanging on a thing
oh jump
i'm dead great unbelievable dude
i'm pissed oh i get to go right
backwards
why do i recognize yours
whoa that's so the voice that guy would
have
nice to ruin my
bowels with all that crap
[Music]
oh dude oh good thing we put the mature
audience on this thing
it's racist that's racist the book is
racist
i'm pissed did i no i did i'm getting it
but they're saying i'm not so their game
is a liar so
go back it does somebody said it takes
honor and commitment and it really does
all right i have honor
here we go i have commitment well i have
commitment to okay
[Music]
honor and commitment dude this is
unbelievable but see now
it's bigger but i can't see what you
guys are saying now what is that
thing you know
good job oh this is the boss
i'm the best twitcher and you're and
you're up there too look here what we're
going to do
like okay
so get on the thing get on the get on
the thing just no
no you see the thing you can get ride
the sucker
ride the sucker right there ride that
sucker no
babe it's the bottom one i'm on the top
one
oh my god god oh my god god
oh my god dude do the dash do the dab
don't just jump we do the dash we jump
and we dash
we jump and we dash dude we get the hang
of it johnny gets the hang of it
okay now watch out for the you can tell
telegraph it with the shadows
we telegraph it with the shadows ride
the sucker dude ride the sucker
babe i don't know what you do you want
to ride the bottom sucker or the top
sucker
get that dog get on that top sucker dude
nothing's happening so far all right we
gotta all right you guys you're
now you're really in oh okay i don't
know what this is this is absolute
horseshit
you don't know where anything is no i i
do i'm the one who figured out
everything about the thing
you just keep talking and through that i
figure out everything
oh no dude look i i wanna i wanna i want
honestly okay
now look i'm getting on the top so i can
do this sucker
okay okay i'm on the top so ride the
bottom dude okay okay
right the bottom i got it she's running
suck it up on the thing
suck up the cans suck up the cans look
what
look at that dude it's beautiful well i
did it mostly but yes
okay but now dude this family has a
problem with what they have in keeping
their trash honestly aerosol clan cans
firecrackers and huge boulders this
family sucks and
now i'm happy there's a strong look ouch
here we go all right now i'm going to
ride the top of you right you ride the
bottom baby here we go
now i'm riding that bottom now suck up
those cans suck up those cans here we go
right up in that dude there we go you
see he thinks he's badass but he's not
doing it did we meet him how's the chats
going dude
i died do the
triangle thing i keep you oh
sorry guys i know you're probably saying
crazy good stuff i can't check the
thing right now because it's intense
all right here we go now i'm going to
ride it now get on the bottom oh [ __ ]
i did the wrong one it's okay oops i did
it again
no don't be doing it again ouch don't be
doing it again
yeah sucked him up sucked him up i set
him up
falling are we on live still yeah
whoa dude whoa the way they do it is so
quick
okay now i'm going to get on the top
okay
oh what oh no i'm trying to refresh the
stream
okay i'm on the bottom can i get on the
chat the bottom
sucking up the thingies you're on the
bottom are you gonna get on the top
i know but i can't already oh why is the
chat my chat not off
ivan do you know
dude all right now we are at a boss this
is the bosses what we finally this is
what we worked for you know what i mean
so
when you get on the bottom one ride it
out and then i'll get on the top one and
then i'll ride it over
here we're gonna suck it up dude suck it
up yeah yeah yeah
boom boom second okay
no don't say that okay we're gonna get
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go
we jumping with dash we jump when we
dash we get dizzy roxy us we get dizzy
but we jump and we dash though
yeah okay i'm disintegrating that's fine
dude that's fine well
survive so i don't have to so i could oh
okay i'll get them
okay all right here we go okay and we
jump in with that
and we just now it's on it's on it's on
up the chat's on oh okay
okay i'll get on the top okay yeah i'm
on the bottom section okay
ahead go ahead oh this takes an infinite
amount of time
how are we still alive on this one we
die we keep dying what do you mean we
keep dying it keeps happening
ouch i'm good at this game and nobody
can take that from me here we go come on
oh i got hit by the aerosol can family
has too many aerosol cans you can only
ground that
here we go here we go here we go okay
now i'm on the top okay here we go here
we go
okay suck them up i did
i did okay i believe you i see it
happening
you know what's kind of [ __ ] that
the wind actually hurts you that
shouldn't happen
i get the aerosol cans i get the
fireworks i get the rocks certainly but
the wind shouldn't hurt it looks like
hurricane
and that vacuum has eyes sure
now we get it look how quick i learned
johnny learns it quick we know johnny
learns it so quick now
it's crazy dude i didn't want you to
know this much about me it took a lot
it took like here we go we got it can
you understand too
though subtle quick diss but like did
you understand
how many subscribers we we gained
because of how much were
time to finish this
his other arm is free come on
put it to his eyes or what
oh i'm pressing pressing the yeah suck
his eyes up
oh that's so gruesome huh
hill he sucked his eyes up out of his
face
god that's so violent his family's
messed up
somebody said johnny thighs cries it's
hip hips cry dude
come on baby okay
you know you do have pretty good
teamwork
are you [ __ ] kidding me
okay now what
what are you doing my hands are sweating
so much
get them in there okay all right now get
the other two in here
[Music]
okay ready now
okay recall and then recall that
or no don't be cool
[ __ ] come on
okay all right we got one okay it's
probably gonna be
oh noise forgot about his eyes oh no
somebody said they said it's really hard
all right here we go
you gotta keep just doing it or what i
think so yeah how many times do you have
to
you guys were really close yeah we were
close
somebody said i feel so bad for their
friends in a room we have no friends
unless they don't mean us we have no
friends
oh i mean i am joking you know
nobody has no friends oh i think we're
in the room
oh in this room oh in this room oh oh
i thought you meant in the chat room yes
the people here feel bad
[Music]
thank god i didn't drink wine i mean
imagine me trying to do that well it'd
be funny
[Music]
god this is so this just sucks dude
don't die
oh [ __ ]
all right here we go watch out
stay far away from me if you can i mean
fly far away from you so he can't hit us
both
[Music]
yeah man we're trying you know
oh
okay here we go ready all right get on
there
oh got it
[Music]
okay we need one more
wha what is that that's happening i'm
pillar so kind of look they're all no
one's
[ __ ] watching anymore go ahead here
we go who cares
[Music]
something i think it just got laid on
pizzas
oh i don't want to finish this
yeah we got you oh okay
we're gonna do it this time babe i can
feel it remember you said that last time
oh yeah
we didn't do it right
watch out are you on it
i think you can only get two
[Music]
i mean this is so hard you know like
i mean it's scary too like i'm scared
oh [ __ ] he sucked me up
come on dude i'm back baby i'm back baby
oh [ __ ] get on the thing okay
you got it yeah okay how many times
i have one more that was the second time
yeah
but this is so it's already too hard i
know i'm gonna cry it's the best you
guys can do
dave you're a great motivator but chad
is loving him
do they really oh my god he's gonna
smack
get away from me no for real get away
from me i'm pissed
okay okay but i get pissed remember oh
wow she keeps trying to tag
me okay now come back
okay it's fine but okay now you're back
get on the spatula
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah dude let's add to it let's add
to it
holy moly
oh man everyone's happy look wow
cute
[Music]
i feel like i really did it why you guys
ripped dude
everyone's happy anyway guys thanks guys
bye oh wait i gotta go dude what uh
what a video game you know what what uh
what a china
have a good one guys
[Music]
you